lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es que
podamos sentirnos un poco más cómodos
con la idea de cadenas de caracteres
strings y también ver lo poderoso que
son los strings y lo que podemos hacer
con ellos así que voy a escribir un
pequeño programa que esencialmente
definirá un montón de cadenas de
caracteres strings y luego usaré todos
esos strings para jugar con ellos en el
intérprete de payton y ver qué podemos
hacer déjenme definir un string que será
a igual a mi primer string de prueba
ya saben que un string es una gran
secuencia de caracteres como aquí y
pueden reconocerlo porque puede estar
entre comillas sencillas o dobles y solo
para mostrar que no es necesario que
sean dobles voy a definirme como otro
string de prueba que he definido
solo para aclarar la manera en que se
pueden definir los strings se pueden
poner las comillas dentro de las
comillas que definen el string siempre
que esté definido en donde empieza y
termina el string digamos que tenemos
algo como esto generalmente se usa en
inglés this is us string en este ejemplo
el apóstrofe está bien es una comida
sencilla pero está bien porque el
intérprete sabe que el string empieza
con comillas dobles y buscará las
comillas dobles para saber dónde termina
se necesitan comillas dobles para
terminar este string y sabe que toda
esta cosa es una cadena de caracteres y
también sabe que el apóstrofe es solo un
carácter algo que no podría hacer es
definir el string de de esta manera
déjenme definir el swing de de una
manera que no es correcta y que no
podría funcionar
this is also string esto no tiene
sentido porque estamos definiendo el
principio del string con comillas
sencillas y aquí cerraríamos el string
con esta comilla entonces a todos
texto que queda fuera el intérprete lo
consideraría como instrucciones del
programa por lo que marcaría errores y
votaría si quieren que esto funcione
correctamente podrían tener algo como lo
siguiente mi palabra y hay maneras de
saltar caracteres y poder hacer que
funcione pero no lo vamos a hacer ahora
mi palabra favorita es oops creo que no
sé cuál es mi palabra favorita digamos
que mi palabra favorita es espárrago
cuál es la tuya y una vez más aquí
parece un poco extraño pero miren
empiezo con comillas sencillas y aunque
el intérprete encuentra estas comillas
dobles sabe que el string no termina
hasta que encuentran comillas sencillas
déjenme mostrarles otros ejemplos de
strings y será interesante hacer este
tipo de ejemplos vamos a poner nombre en
las etiquetas o variables esta se
llamará string matemático string
matemático y digamos que es igual a 3 +
4 x 2
es un string matemático simplemente un
string literalmente una cadena de
caracteres que el intérprete no va a
evaluar sólo la va a considerar una
cadena de caracteres déjenme hacer otro
ejemplo matemático otra expresión
matemática y vamos a llamar a este
string expresión matemática
solo es el nombre de la variable esta
expresión matemática es igual a a más
parecerá que tengo un tipo de string
dentro de otro string más b más tigre
así está bien todo lo que está dentro de
las comillas dobles el intérprete lo
considerará como un string simplemente
un montón de caracteres pero veremos más
adelante las cosas tan interesantes que
podemos hacer con esto hemos definido
suficientes strings déjenme salvarlo y
correr lo voy a correrlo y lo que vamos
a hacer es verificar todos los streams
que hemos definido y decimos a mi primer
string de prueba de otro string de
prueba que he definido ser this is us
string todo esto en inglés de mi palabra
favorita es espárrago cual es la tuya es
difícil deletrear esa palabra veamos
cómo se ve el string matemático
literalmente una cadena de caracteres
y por último la expresión matemática
igual una cadena de caracteres
simplemente una cadena de caracteres
ahora empecemos a jugar con algunos de
estos strings y ver qué podemos hacer
con ellos si queremos saber la longitud
de alguno diremos cuantos caracteres
tiene este string y podemos usar la
función lento que viene con python leen
que es una forma corta del int longitud
así que decimos lente a y ya tiene 26
caracteres
vamos a contar los vamos a verificarlo 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16 17
18 19 20 21 22 23 24 25 26 y 26
caracteres
cuál es la longitud del string
matemático leen es la forma corta del en
longitud
en the string matemático
y es cinco caracteres uno dos tres
cuatro cinco esto tiene sentido les
recomiendo que practiquen esto que
experimenten hasta que se sientan
cómodos trabajando con strings ahora lo
siguiente que quiero mostrarles es cómo
concatenar dos streams esta palabra
suena como algo difícil pero realmente
concatenar significa conectar o juntar
por ejemplo vamos a crear un nuevo
sprint le llamaremos a con b y lo
definiremos como a + b estoy haciendo
algo muy interesante estamos
acostumbrados a usar el signo más con
números pero ahora lo usaremos para
sumar todos sus trinos
es como si sumáramos dos strings vamos a
ver lo que resulta en a come a con b es
una variable y qué pasa tengo que ar
es mi primer string de prueba y ve que
es otro string de prueba que he definido
cuando le digo a más de el intérprete
toma mi primer string de prueba y le
suma ve al final concatena va a poner a
ive juntos mi primer string de prueba y
otro string de prueba que he definido
creo que es fácil ver cómo ve está al
final de a
y podemos hacerlo de otra manera podemos
definir beacon a igual a b más a y
veamos lo que resulta ve con a ahora es
al revés a fue añadido a b y pueden usar
muchas facetas de los strings también
podríamos hacer string matemático más
expresión matemática no voy a definir
ninguna variable para esto solo voy a
ver que resulta así evaluó esto string
matemático más expresión matemática
esencialmente lo que obtenemos son los
dos strings juntos este string fue
puesto al final de este string y vemos
que resulta algo muy extraño pero es un
string todo lo que está entre las
comillas dobles se evalúa como
caracteres son simplemente caracteres
hay muchas otras cosas que podemos hacer
con strings no voy a introducirlos en
todo eso hay muchas funciones en python
que se pueden usar con strings y si
están usando el entorno de desarrollo
integrado muchas veces les sugiere los
tipos de funciones que pueden usar por
ejemplo tal vez quieran dividir un
string probablemente quieran una lista
de las palabras que contiene un string
tal vez están escribiendo un programa y
quieran usar el string b y poner cada
palabra como un elemento separado en una
lista entonces lo que podemos hacer es
decir b punto y llamar a uno de los
métodos de be y podremos hacer mucho más
con los métodos que si programamos todo
eso estamos viendo a b como un objeto
string y
sus propios métodos que operan en este
objeto para este ejemplo podemos decir
si quiero dividir ve en sus componentes
debo llamar el método split y le puedo
decir que es lo que quiero dividir a
partir si uso split significa separar el
string en partes y ponerlas en una lista
así que hacemos split en este string
cada vez que vea un espacio y vamos a
ver qué resulta de esto miren como el
string otro string de prueba que he
definido y lo separo en donde hay
espacios y tomo cada cosa que había
antes y después de los espacios y lo
puso como elementos de una lista esto
sería muy útil si hacen un tipo de
procesamiento de textos pero quiero
mostrarles que no sólo hace división o
separación en donde hay espacios podemos
decir b punto split y decirle que haga
una división o una separación cada vez
que encuentre una
así que diremos b punto split
y pone cada parte como un elemento
separado de la lista justo aquí se
pueden hacer cosas fascinantes pueden
hacer cosas como encontrar caracteres en
una lista digamos que queremos encontrar
un carácter en el string matemático
hacemos string matemático punto find que
es uno de sus métodos y hacemos find
asterisco queremos encontrar este
asterisco dime si alguno de los
caracteres es un asterisco y nos dice
que el tercer carácter es uno vamos a
verificar este es el primer carácter no
no no es el carácter de la posición 0 se
inicia con la posición 0 como una
convención en muchos lenguajes de
programación primero segundo tercero el
tercer carácter es un asterisco si
quieren encontrar un 3 los animo a que
experimenten con esto encuentren el 3
que es el carácter en la posición 0 hay
otra cosa que pueden hacer como
reemplazar caracteres pueden decir vamos
a tomarse y reemplazar todo esto lo
pueden encontrar en un libro buscando en
la web pueden encontrar todas las
librerías de payton para strings si
están usando el y del entorno de
desarrollo integrado les sugiere lo que
pueden hacer con strings y les dice cómo
hacerlo bueno digamos que queremos
reemplazar del string sé todas las y es
por os vamos a ver que obtenemos aquí
vamos el string se originalmente es this
is also string cuando reemplazamos las
íes por os quiero aclarar esto python no
cambia el string sino que crea una copia
de cee con los caracteres reemplazados y
nos queda dos shows sales strong esto
suena como un lenguaje nórdico o algo
así y sólo para tener esto claro se no
cambia pero si decimos que es igual hace
punto replace y reemplazamos las íes por
dos entonces se cambia a todos sal
strong
ahora la última cosa que quiero mostrar
es una función casi mágica desde mi
punto de vista es la función
evans existe en intérpretes como python
también existe en javascript pero lo que
es realmente padre es que puede evaluar
un string pueden crear un sprint lo
pueden ir construyendo y pueden por
ejemplo tener un programa que escribe
otro programa dentro de un string y
luego evaluar ese programa de
computadora esto les hará pensar un poco
por ejemplo si decimos string matemático
nos muestra solo una cadena de
caracteres porque estoy matemático es
sólo una cadena de caracteres pero si
decimos eval string matemático
el intérprete va a evaluar lo que está
dentro de esta cadena de caracteres y lo
va a considerar como una expresión y lo
va a evaluar y el resultado es 11
el intérprete toma el string matemático
y dice ok trataré esto como un programa
3 + 4 por 2 por el orden de las
operaciones
hace 4 por 2 que es 8 + 3 es 11 y
podemos hacer cosas más padres podríamos
decir eh vale
pensemos en este string matemático y
añadir a este string matemático un
carácter el carácter 1 veamos lo que
hace obtenemos 87 pero que hizo lo que
hizo fue añadir 1 al final del string
matemático que es esto y si añadimos un
1 se vería así en lugar de dos
sería 21 si con acá tenemos el 1 al
final del 8 y matemático tendríamos 4
por 21 es 84 más 3 es 87 y podríamos
evaluar esta expresión matemática que
tenemos aquí por eso le escribimos así
evans expresión matemática es realmente
divertido hacer esto vale expresión
matemática
recuerden expresión matemática y sólo un
string pero lo podemos evaluar obtuvimos
todo esto de donde vino en él
ahí ve eran solo caracteres pero cuando
lo evaluamos como una expresión en el
contexto en el que estamos trabajando
hay bessón variables que representan
strings
así que si evaluamos estas cosas el
intérprete dirá ok a es este string mi
primero string de prueba y le pondrá un
espacio al final así que quedan y primer
string de prueba un espacio y después
pone b que es otro string de prueba que
he definido luego pone un espacio y
tigre así que vemos un espacio y tigre'
los voy a dejar aquí como pueden
imaginar los strings son conceptos súper
poderosos y se pueden hacer un montón de
aplicaciones ni siquiera ha estado cerca
de agotar todas las funciones que se
pueden usar los animo a que experimenten